we have so far been looking at calculus
of exponential and logarithmic functions
you can see them all over the board
but you might be able to guess by
looking at this piece of paper that
you've got in front of you that we're
going to kind of push past those
exponential and logarithmic functions
it's not labeled but what kind of a
function is this yeah go ahead dean
this is sine x right not exponential
it's not logarithmic what bigger family
of functions does sine x belong to
starts with a t
yeah trigonometric functions right so
there's sign there's cos there's tan
this whole big thing and there's like
reciprocals there's does anyone remember
what the reciprocals are by the way it's
like
sec
cosec and cot right this is like a whole
big world out there much like once we
learn exponentials and logs you're like
oh now i have all these different things
to play with it's gonna be the same deal
with trigonometric functions now some of
you if you're like me you're like
i'm slightly nervous sort of walking
into this big world
but i kind of want to hopefully get you
excited about this because i want you to
feel
the feeling that mathematic
mathematicians do
when they're inventing
mathematics
actually i sat down prematurely i just
put your things down for a second i just
want to say something really important
to you
um
i'm going to preface what i'm about to
say
with a very important statement that you
might think is not true except i'm
pointing it out very obviously
i really love science i think it's one
of the most amazing subjects you guys
have the opportunity to study
i wish i had studied more of it when i
was at high school
however
one of the things that really frustrates
me i don't know if how many of you do a
science any science
all of you
except for you of us oh no sorry two of
you okay
you just
i just dropped physics um rip that's
okay thanks sansa um actually unlike you
guys i didn't do any physics in years 11
12 not because i didn't like it but
because i just didn't have like i did 14
units there's already too many okay now
despite that i love science but the
thing that always frustrated me was and
i don't know if this is your feeling
either
is that what you do in science is often
very different from what scientists
actually do
does that make sense let me say it again
what you do in science is often very
different from what scientists do
because they're busy like researching
trying to like discover new stuff and
what you guys mostly do is actually the
opposite of that you
study and learn the stuff that's already
been discovered by somebody else does
that make sense so like you do some
experiments and you try to you know like
go through the same kind of scientific
process and so on and that's like thumbs
up however it's not like any of you are
like
fiddling with radioactive substances for
the first time and accidentally making
your diaries radioactive for the next
300 years like marie curie did you just
kind of like following in her footsteps
thankfully safety and all that but
you're not actually doing science the
way that a scientist does does that make
sense okay
now max i get it sometimes feels the
same way like these rules we kind of
showed you how they work but for the
most part you're following what someone
else did but i kind of want to blow the
lid off that
with this
this is as daniel pointed out and we
should actually label it as such this is
y equals sine x maybe you want to put it
over here on the right hand side
y equals sine
x
and sine x is i guess you could call it
like the primordial trigonometric
function every other trigonometric
function gets its definition from sine x
and actually you kind of maybe already
knew that in the back of your mind if
you could tell me like you all did what
the names of the other functions are for
example
cos x right do you guys know it's an
abbreviation what's an abbreviate what's
cause an abbreviation four yeah
cosine right
co
sine so clearly even just from the name
cosine takes its definition
from sine um does anyone know what the
code stands for by the way it's also an
abbreviation
it stands for complement right which we
will get back to later on has to do with
angles that add up to 90 degrees okay
so you've got the complement of sine
what's the other main trigonometric
function you guys know about
it's saturday
it's tan right or which is also short
for tangent but this is like are you
getting a sense like mathematician's so
lazy we abbreviate everything
tan is an abbreviation for a fraction
what's the fraction
it's sine
over cos so you can see it's like
there's sine again and i'll just write
it in long form just to make it really
obvious there's sine again right so if
you understand sine you understand
everything in trigonometry so that's why
i've just given you the one graph and
we're going to try and unpack
what is the derivative of this right now
some of you know an answer to this
question already
but i separate that from do you
understand
why
do you understand how it is that you can
get the derivative for this the result
the formula we've been using formulas
all morning they're great because
they're fast but they are no substitute
a formula is no substitute for really
knowing why something is the way that it
is
so
i said right at the beginning i would
love you to get a ruler out if you've
got one can you just wave it around at
me and yes if you've got one just so i
can see how many of you have one
okay if you've got a straight edge
that's better than nothing thank you
hands down but the ruler actually will
be useful okay
now
i want you to remember and maybe you
want to do this actually just um just
underneath or in your book perhaps is
the best way to put it
we've had a look at different functions
like say
why do i do it like that like say the
exponential function draw me another
quick and dirty exponential function
like so
and also we've had a look at the log
function
and we've said
you can actually understand a lot about
the derivatives of these without any
symbols without any algebra just by
looking at the geometry the shape the
visual of it right
for example we all notice that the
derivative of an exponential
the gradient of an exponential looks
like an exponential it starts low and
positive and it becomes
big and positive right and that's
exactly what an exponential function
does
in much the same way though we got a
very different result when you look at
the log right do you remember what we
said
it's positive but instead of going from
a low gradient to a high gradient it
goes from a high like a steep gradient
to a shallow gradient from
high gradient to low so therefore we
ended up with do you remember this curve
here what was its equation do you
remember
if we start with y equals log x i mean
you've written it on the board right
one over x very good so d y on dx
it's this familiar
hyperbola right at least one part of it
okay now we want to go through the same
kind of visual exercise to try and
develop intuition for what's going on
with the trigonometric curve as you can
see
it's not nearly as simple as the
exponential or the log you can't say oh
it just like starts low and goes up it
like does this weird waving around thing
right um it repeats by the way we have a
special name for when a function repeats
itself over and over again it starts
with a p does anyone remember what it is
periodic fantastic so the periodicity
the periodicity
of this function is weird but also means
if we can just understand a small
section of it then we just take that
understanding and just copy it over and
over again every period it will look the
same which is why you can notice off the
end here right
you can see this value here i've kind of
just left it off like after that because
it's just going to be the same over and
over again
okay
now the last thing to note is there's a
weird scale going on with this and i'm
not going to fully explain in too much
detail but these aren't degrees aren't
they does anyone know what this scale is
because you'd expect that to be 180
degrees does anyone know what it is
daniel
he's a radiance right in fact go ahead
and label this for me right there in the
middle have i moved my thing no i
haven't right there in the middle there
that's an important number in radians
you might be able to guess it just by
looking at the scale it's just a bit up
to three what's the important number
just after three in radians it's
it's pi right so there's pi if we went a
little bit further over
you can see this number that's just
after six to give us the full copy of
the trigonometric curve it's not pi it's
2 pi fantastic
so this is a horizontal scale in radians
and that's essential because what we're
going to now do and i'm going to give
you two examples of this and then i'm
going to ask you to do it for the rest
of the curve
we're going to try and understand not
just like roughly what does the
derivative look like
we actually want to measure the thing
okay
so let's zoom in real close and have a
look at what's going on in the left-hand
corner okay
and do you remember when we were having
a look at the exponential log curves we
started putting tangents on those curves
we said hey look at what the gradient
looks like right
so at each of these points you could
draw a teeny little tangent and what i'm
going to do is ask you to do that for a
few of the locations which you're going
to choose on the graph but i will give
you the first one for free because i'm
just nice like that okay let's start
from x equals zero
go ahead and take your ruler now right
and i want you to to place it align it
with the graph
so that you end up with a tangent i hope
you end up with something that looks a
little bit like this
let me there we go
do you get something roughly like that
that hopefully is where your ruler looks
like i'm just trying to mimic it because
i don't have a ruler to put on the
screen okay now once you've got that
ruler in place oopsy daisy i actually
want you to go ahead and draw
part of that tangent you don't want to
draw too much because we're going to
draw a bunch of these okay maybe
this would be enough i would say
something like that let me make this a
bit thicker so you can see it more
clearly
hopefully you can see that oops
all right
so here's my tangent okay now to measure
the gradient of something you just need
two things on a straight line you need
its rise and you need its run yeah rise
over run gives you gradient so therefore
along with this tangent what i'd like
you to draw and i'll do this dotted so
it's not going to cloud my diagram too
much go ahead and draw a rise and run
for that little tangent so you can see
i'm going to get this right angled
triangle in here okay
now i said
a rule would be really helpful because
what i'm going to ask you to do now is
to actually measure what those two
things are like how tall is this thing
what is this height and what is this
with what are the rise
and what are the run and as we've seen
and just sort of stated right gradient
is rise
over run
now because this is a really easy one
you actually might be able to even use
the scale of this to c right have a look
at my scale that i've provided to you if
this is one
how big is each of these little squares
well how how wide is each one
0.2 yeah so let's go ahead and we'll
actually write this on here 0.2 is
pretty much how high it goes and 0.2
is basically how wide it is okay
so in this case gradient rise everyone
will be 0.2 over 0.2 which is
we can do 0.2 over 0.2 even though you
just had a weekend of no math
it's one right okay gradient equals one
for this particular tangent
now i'm going to sort of scaffold a
little bit more but i'm not gonna tell
you the answer find a different spot
anywhere you like and i'd really love it
actually if you picked different spots
to the people around you like you don't
have to all do the same spot but if for
instance let me just temporarily move
this out of the way i'll put it back in
a second but
let's pick a spot like say
here
it's a bit random right but i'm going to
do the same thing and i'm going to place
my ruler up against this and try and
measure a gradient okay so it looks to
me if i were to draw that tangent across
it'll be something like this
does that look pretty
well i can do better than that i reckon
i reckon it's going to be a bit more
like that
does that look pretty tangential to you
zoomed out unintentionally okay now at
the same in the same way
i can draw on my little triangle right i
keep on zooming out by accident because
my
pen is too uncoordinated so i'm going to
draw a really nice thick line across
here like so
and i'm going to do the same
rise and run now you have to be
you have to be as precise as you can
better than what i've done right but
you're going to measure these same
things right
here
and here
and i'm going to be able to work out
whatever this rise is
divided by whatever this run is and that
will give me a new gradient but i can
already see even just by eyeballing it
that if i compare that to this one here
it's going to be a little bit keep doing
that it's going to be a little shallower
do you agree
one last one and i'm not going to tell
you the answer but hopefully you can see
it once you get to a spot like say
that's going to drive me crazy this spot
here
without even drawing a triangle you
might be able to tell me what the
gradient is at that point and you can
write there gradient equals whatever you
think it actually equals
so i'm going to pause there
you guys have your rulers you've got
hopefully some colors might help you in
that kind of thing
find six seven eight points and then
once you've got a bunch of gradients
we're actually gonna plot those on and
see what they make okay off you go